okay let's talk a little bit about masks
briefly uh donald trump traveled to
arizona yesterday went to a honeywell
facility that is making masks because we
have a pandemic
and people should be wearing masks that
factory requires masks and donald trump
refused to wear a mask
instead trump wore goggles which is okay
i mean fine but it's a little weird
given that he didn't wear the mask
trump was asked as he was leaving the
white house yesterday on his way to
arizona
will you wear a mask and trump said i
will if it is a
mask facility say it do you think
we're a master uh it's a i think it's a
mask
facility right if it's a mask facility i
will yeah i don't know if it's a masked
facility but
honey we're going to see honeywell they
have done an incredible job on many
fronts and so i'm going to pay my
respects to a great company
and a great state the state of arizona
they make n95 they make masks
as trump says if it's a mask facility
trump says that he will wear one well as
you can see in this video that we are
playing
there are safety guidelines prominently
displayed at this honeywell facility
and they say please wear your mask
at all times in addition to observing
six feet of social distance
as well as using hand sanitizer and yet
here is donald trump standing 18 inches
from another guy
wearing goggles but no mask as the guy
shows him a mask they have a crate of
masks
in front of them you couldn't parody
this on saturday night live
the factory policy is wear a mask at all
times
and trump puts on goggles but no mask
and his aides are also not wearing masks
now why do we care about this
is it just disaster porn no we care
about this because more than 60 million
people in this country voted for this
guy
many of those people see trump as a
demigod and they do whatever he does
and if trump goes to a mask facility and
he doesn't wear a mask
it encourages this exact type of
behavior that we don't need right now so
we can laugh it off we can say okay you
know trump wore goggles and no mask he's
just personally kind of a
weird dude or an idiot but it doesn't
really have an impact
this will fuel more right wingers not
wearing masks and actually being opposed
to them
this sends the message that wearing a
mask isn't that important even when the
policy
of a location is masks at all times
it encourages people to ignore it if
they see trump ignoring the policy
that's
in large print on a tv and probably
multiple tvs
trump's own administration has said
covering your mask is better than not
cover
covering your face rather is better than
not covering your face
if you don't have a mask wear a scarf
trump said
well they had masks it's a mask factory
i would wear one if they require it
but then he doesn't and of course that
puts people
around trump at risk and it puts trump
himself
at risk the message that is being sent
his masks are no big deal coronavirus is
no big deal
everything's fine and yet 2
350 people died in the united states
yesterday
but remember he's wearing goggles this
is the same guy who looked at a solar
eclipse
directly so it's not a question of
trump's intelligence that seems to be
lacking
but how does no one put a mask on the
guy and it's because of what we call
management by
optics okay it's the optics of
this is no big deal and we won if trump
hasn't been seen with a mask
once during the entire pandemic and he
hasn't and then he claims we've
basically won
we can start taking apart the pandemic
response the white house coronavirus
task force rather
if he then shows up with a mask for the
first time the optics don't match
i admit that that's the case if you're
trying to say we've won
you don't start wearing a mask on week
nine of the pandemic
this is management by optics period
and that is very dangerous nordvpn
one of our sponsors is giving you 70 off
a three-year plan which is just a little
over three bucks a month and you'll get
an extra month free when you go to
nordvpn.com
david pakman or go to their website use
the coupon code david pakman
if you don't use a vpn now is the time
to start i always use a vpn on my
computer and my phone
it makes you totally anonymous when
you're browsing online you won't be
spied on
websites can't track you around the
internet your data is safe
from hackers and nordvpn is the one you
want to go with
because they don't keep records on your
internet history they double encrypt
your data
their servers are super fast and they
provide unlimited bandwidth
nordvpn is giving you 70 off a
three-year plan that's just over three
bucks a month
plus an extra month free when you go to
nordvpn.com
david pakman i've put a link right
underneath the video or just go to their
website and use the coupon code
david pakman